ambiance morose pour un match de bas de
tableau le derby de tous les dangers à
tour 18e et premiers relégables on se
veut positif je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
va faire quelque chose et qu'on va s'en
sortir parce qu'on a deux matches à
domicile et ses deux matches là pour
parler perth les supportes quoi qu'il
arrive dans les bons comme dans les
mauvais moments
je suis là aujourd'hui je serai là
demain j'espère encore en ligue 2
j'espère même son cloche côté
châteauroux lanterne rouge du
championnat les supporters de la berri
veulent y croire ils sont une petite
quarantaine à avoir fait le déplacement
pour un 1er juin dernier malheureusement
n'est dernier on va se battre après le
problème bas ça peut être les dirigeants
ça peut être les joueurs c'est pas
vraiment nous on sait notre passion va
se battre pour sauver je suis persuadé
qu'on s'y maintenir peut-être pas de la
même manière comme la saison dernière
mais bon ce matériau dans super cd ya
trop de clubs qui sont repêchés la
saison passée châteauroux peut encore
mathématiquement se sauver mais l'espoir
s'amenuise au fil des matches tours
guère mieux lotis secret les occasions
les plus franches en première période
avec notamment ce coup franc de de l'or
sur la transversale 0 partout à la pause
petit match gros enjeu la deuxième
mi-temps est fatal à la berri réduite à
dix après l'exclusion de dudouit 67e
minute bonne foi pousse le ballon dans
son propre but tout en mène 1 à 0
châteauroux est au fond du trou
c'est forcément difficile si je dis le
contraire je suis pas lucide
effectivement ça devient de plus en plus
difficile oui sportifs de haut niveau
contre 56 possible doit pas lâcher pour
pour plein de choses pour au club pour
l'histoire du club pour les gens qui
travaillent pour les supporters des
supporters qui auront attendu vainement
une égalisation tour s'impose et peut
penser au maintien sportif à savoir si
des finances en suivant aujourd'hui plus
de la moitié des dettes sont payés ça
veut dire quand même qu'il en reste
encore mais dans maintenant
quatorze mois tout sera terminé exercice
plus facile à tenir en ligue 2 caen
nationale reste huit journées de
championnat pour sortir de la zone rouge
sinon il faudra miser sur le retrait
éventuel de certaines équipes